こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ここはスタジオなんだけども、
ちょっといまターゲットを買い出しに行かせてるんですけども、
もうすぐ多分帰ってくると思います。
これ使えるんじゃね？みたいなものを見つけたのでちょっとそれを使って今回
どっきりというか
どきっ💛と
させてみようと思います。
でゅるでゅる
あ⤴っ、、こぼれたコーヒー⤵
も⤴う→も⤴う→薄々気付いたでしょう
これ、コーヒーがこぼれたような偽物です。（ドヤァ
バリバリ―。
この部分ですね。
コーヒーこぼれてる感が出せるんです。（ドヤァ
っと一回出してみましょうか。
ネットで買ったんですけど～
すっごいリアルだったんで
それがいったいど↑れ位リアルなのかっていうのがちょっと知りたいと思っておりま
しゅ
うおぅ、、はぁっ、これ剥がせるよね、、
うわぁ、ハハハ（嘲笑
ちとまっ置かないとわかんないよね
机の上に置く
あぁ～でもぽいな、ぽいぽいぽい
んじゃこれでもうコーヒーこうしてたら、、
あ完全にこぼれてるわ（カァ～～～～ッ
これは完全にこぼれてますｗｗ
うわっこっこれはもうどうっこれっ（動揺
これもうだってもうどう見てもこぼれてるよ
の飲まないと飲まないと
空にすることから始めねぇとな（イケボ風
でゅるっでゅっでゅるでゅるでゅるぢゅっぢゅる
っっっっっっう”う”う”え”ぇ”
ちとまっこれで空になったからぁ
こうやったら、、
っっっっっすっげぇコーヒーこぼれてる感しかなくないですか、、！
すごっやばっ！見て俺待って
え大分すごいよこれぇ
この反射が１００点（誰
はいっはい！はいはいっ！はいはい！はいはい！
というわけで早速、このこぼれたコーヒーを使って、かばんあさってみて
大事そうな、なんか、なにかがあったら
そこにちょっとコーヒーこぼしたようなふりをしておこうと思います。
、っはっはっはっへっへっへ、、（声にならない悪魔
へっへっへ（もはや犬
怖いでござるよ～
、、怖い？（汗
えぃえぇ？（汗
夜中にしてないってドッキリなんて。。
、、いやぁ～～～～
ちょえちょばかじゃないの
いやぁ、、、
ばかっすよ。。
、、、っちょ！！！！
ドタドタ）おい！（ッカンッ
カランカランッ、、。
ええっ！！
ｈｈｈっはははは
ｈｈｈっはははははは
て↓て↑て↓て↑て↓て↑て↓て↑て↓て↑て↓て↑て↓て↑て↓て↑
いやっこれはやばいでしょ
うん完全にわかんないもん
じゃあ、こうやってて、こうやってちょっと、
んでこう寝ぼけててこう、こぼしちゃったみたいな
んおっけぇ
んてゅすか教師。
へはぁちょっと、、！
、、あっなぁ、、ｗｗ
はははははは（嘲笑
あぁ～焦った今ｗ